okay so we're making some progress we've
already gotten two games in
for those of you
um
recently joining
this is a third speed run in which
essentially
and it's very similar to the first two
i'm not gonna lie
but uh
the the idea here is to play very
traditional conservative openings
at least until i'm 12 or 1300 and really
get deep into the fundamentals
because i think one of the comments from
my previous ones has been
that sometimes i tend to win fast out of
the opening especially in the earlier
games
and i wanted to sort of rectify that
this time i'm not saying i'm not going
to win quick games but
we're going to try to emphasize middle
game
middle game play and and fundamentals
all right let's go
[Music]
we're playing a 1400 so we've played up
a couple of games now
but that's fine with me
and we are playing absolute classical
openings queen's gambit declined with
black
e4 e5 okay so this is
this is the queen's gambit declined
which i recommend to every beginner
it's it's sort of a gateway opening for
for a lot of other stuff and in this
position the traditional move is bishop
e7 but if you want to play with a little
bit of an edge
uh i'm sure some of you are familiar
with this move knight b to d7 which
looks like it blunders upon and
you'll be surprised at how many people
fall into this trap c takes d5 and then
knight takes d5
um
but then after knight takes d5 bishop
takes queen there's bishop before check
and black wins a beast i'll show that
after the game this is a very very
famous trap
that's been around for a very very long
time
e3 is of course the main move and now
we develop our bishop to e7 why e7 and
not d6 well mostly because white is
pinning us so now white is threatening
to win this pawn so it's it's time for
us to unpin
okay
now
we would like to complete our
development with castle short
our kingside development at least
and then we have to decide what to do
with this bishop now there's a couple of
ways to play this type of position a
couple of ways to play the sniper
position
um and and this line has been around
since you know the 1800s
um a lot of people like to play b6 and
bishop b7
perfectly
perfectly reasonable line but i'm going
to show you guys a a system that i only
know by the russian name
which roughly translates to
uh the simplifying system of capablanca
so this was introduced to me by my coach
many years ago
i am entirely clueless as to modern
theory i haven't played this myself
since i was 1600 so get take this with a
grain of salt the move looks bad i'm
going to warn you the move looks bad it
looks passive you play c6
okay now you might say
all right c6 maybe it doesn't look that
bad
but it does leave this bishop
pretty hemmed in
never play c6
now we do something
which might seem even more paradoxical
we take on c4 now notice that i have
waited for white
to move his light squared bishop once
uh now i take on c4 and essentially i
win a tempo
and here once again there are two setups
that i'm familiar with one involves a
more aggressive move b5 and then bishop
b7
but
the capoblanca system that i
uh that that i was referring to does
anybody know
what i'm referring to what move leads to
essentially for simplification to some
degree
and don't worry this is not a draw or
anything like that
well a5 is not a simplifying move
no c5
also not a simplifying i'm looking for
piece trades knight d5 yeah knight t5 is
the simplifying move
it invites a trade of dark squared
bishops we'll of course recapture with
the queen to keep the knight on a
stronghold
and
i think the great thing about this
system is it really
it really teaches you how pieces and
pawns work because at first sight
black's position seems to be
quite a bit worse passive bishop
white has more central control i can
play e4 at some point even now
but in reality the position is very
close to equal
a lot of this has to do with the lack of
weaknesses in black's position this is a
very underrated thing
that people don't always realize when
you don't have any weaknesses
i mean your position is going to be very
hard to crack even if
even if uh your position is
very passive
all right that's just a fact about chess
that you have to factor in
now we continue to simplify
we continue to simplify
and the other thing about this type of
structure is that
we can uncoil our pawns with a timely e5
e5 immediately blunders upon right
because the knight on d5 is going to be
left
insufficiently protected
so we take on c3 first and then we
expand with e5 we kind of uncoil
and later we can open our bishop and
develop it along this diagonal so e5
this is essentially as far as i know the
position is very balanced let's see if
we can win
if we can win the resulting position
which is very simple
okay d takes c5 knight takes c5 this guy
is playing very well i have to say
he's playing
great moves
so let's see
[Music]
whether we can make something happen in
this position
i think it's clear that black has
essentially equalized the only thing
that remains is for us to get our bishop
out but should be six is good
to neutralize white's bishop if i were
white i would be contemplating a move
like queen b3 to discourage bishop e6
yeah four is not scary at four we drop
our queen back
and f4 doesn't really
scare us that much once again black's
position is so solid no targets
white's position two but
we're playing black so we're obviously
trying to equalize out of the opening
okay queen c2
and we have two distinct ways to develop
our bishop bishop e6 i mentioned
previously
the other one is of course to play
bishop f5 with tempo
but again the way we're playing in the
speed run is just to emphasize
very simple chess and and fundamentals
even if it means
getting into a drawn position
even if it means getting into a wrong
position so let's complete our
development we fully equalize of course
we want to take with the queen we don't
want to ruin our pawn structure
and i'm i'm actually hoping that he
plays queen b3 because
i want to play an end game
so what's our next moves going to what
is our next c sequence of moves going to
be we're probably going to go rook d8
it's a good idea to create some lift and
that is a
lapse in concentration by our opponent
who can tell me why
it's a free pawn
now before taking such a pawn you just
verify that your queen isn't getting
trapped
always a necessary step because
okay queen takes a2 he can play rook a3
but our queen safely returns back to e6
the square where it came from thank you
very much for the pawn
now we need to be careful
so
who wants to propose a move here
yeah so some of you are proposing g6
which is a good move
but it allows rook d7 i don't want to
allow rook d7 so the mover fda comes to
mind but if you calculate rook ft8 you
can trade
and then you can play the move rook to
a3 forking the queen and the a pawn
all right and just these queen side
pawns you got to be very careful about
so i propose a a much simpler move which
is just to return with the queen to e6
and you guys are getting it
back to e6 i guess i'm allowing rook t3
so it's not entirely clear but still
yeah rook d3 good good stuff by my
opponent
all right so how do we deal with this he
wants rook d7
can't stop it by playing rook d8
so
what we need to do is ask ourselves
all right
after he goes rook d7 what do we want to
be able to play
we don't necessarily want to go rook ba
that's very passive
i'll talk about
passive and active defense afterward but
there is a
a
relatively common technique for dealing
with a rook infiltration to the seventh
rank
okay this is sort of a is something that
you can kind of commit to memory and
that is the move rook fe-8 first
with the idea of meeting rook d7 with
rook e7
essentially forcing and very important
detail of course rook d8 is not made we
take it and we drop the rook back to e8
rook d6 this guy is good this guy is no
joke
all right let's think i was planning
queenie five in this position
i think queenie five is just fine
oh he's got something crazy there
you just think
yeah i'm trying to figure out maybe it's
actually not the queen's theater queen
e5 let's go queen e5
maybe three
another excellent move
preparing work d7
now queen f5 we can take
i think a queen b5
yeah queen b5 let's go queen b5 again
not blundering mate rook d8 check we
have a rook e8
at the first opportunity i'm going to
create some lift
yet i don't see like a mate or anything
here i hope i'm not blundering something
now notice the x-ray defense right
notice the x-ray defense okay now we're
up upon i'm happy
the problem is that he's got this super
active rogue first of all we have to
defend this pawn i don't see a reason to
just give it away
so let's go rookie to b8 we could have
also gone b6 but
rook d5 we have to defend this pawn he's
not leaving me with much choice
ah very nicely played rook c5 and then
rook c7
yeah so this is going to be a draw
because we have to
prevent the rook from doubling on the
seventh ring so let's go rook bc8
basically allowing him to take v7
now let's create some luft
with
g6 for
example and i'm gonna do my best to win
this actually
who can give me a club or move here we
have a very clever move it doesn't
really work but it's a good try
yeah we can give him a check first and
then go rook c2
or we can go rook a1 we can try to be we
can try to be fancy let's go rook c2 and
let's hope he doesn't yeah okay he does
find gg3
all right now we take it and it's a draw
you can go h5 here just to create
the ideal pawn structure push the b-pawn
rook b1 we're just going to try to push
the b-pawn all the way and see what
happens
sometimes people mess up in those
positions
let's give him a check on b2 you see
he's already not okay so he what is he
doing
now he's just giving up all the pawns
and now he's giving up another one we
can win this pawn with rook g3
yeah very str i mean honestly very
strange play because he was playing
excellent and then he just gave
everything up and resigned
accuracy was nice 90 to 97.
no i think he's legit i just just think
he's good i don't know what to say
okay
all right all right guys let's take a
look at the game
let's take a look at the game
okay so
queen's gambit decline now the line here
c takes d5e takes d5 knight takes d5
remember this
knight takes d5
bishop takes queen and bishop before
check it's not mate he's got queen d2
you can either take on d8 or take on d2
and at the end of the day you're up with
peace
i've seen some 15 1600s fall into this
by the way so knight pd7 is a great way
to make a theoretical move while also
setting a trap
while also sending a trap
okay
um
e3 bishop e7 knight f3 castles rook c1
again
there's multiple moves in this position
b6
is one of them
um
let me see c6 is the main move two
thousand
uh 100 games so we followed the main
line dc4
and knight t5
yeah this is over a thousand games in
this position so it's a very reputable
system
this is all mainline
if he goes e4
then we take on c3
and who can tell me let's say rook takes
c3 how black should respond here
and this is one of the main ideas of of
the line of course
not queen before so queen b4 is tempting
but very superficial right
think about it this way
is the black queen operating alone going
to really cause a lot of damage for
example queen c2 i want to remind you of
an important point i made in the first
speed run how do you assess whether pins
are dangerous so there's two factors you
have to consider the first thank you
great odin's raven for the five gifted
the first factor is whether the pinned
piece is defended by a pawn if it is
pins are generally less dangerous that
should be
intuitive right because if this rook
wasn't defended by a pawn it would be a
lot more vulnerable the second
is how temporary is the pin likely to be
pins
against the king that is if the king
is at the end of the pin not the pin
piece but i call it the uh the penny
um
and the king is likely to castle on the
next move then the pin
loses
you know its value greatly
so
here white's gonna castle on the next
move white can also play a3 b4 that's
why queens aren't very good at
delivering pins or at holding pins
because they're so easy to chase away
so this doesn't do anything whoops my
bad
um
any other attempts yeah so chris
mistronic got it
the move here is e5 we have to contest
the center
we have to contest the center and our
pieces notice how perfectly poised they
are they're both controlling e5
and in the event of a trade
black is in excellent shape here we're
attacking e4 we can go bishop b6 just
because white is a little bit more space
in the center doesn't mean white's
better
all right so space advantage itself is
not a reason to be overly concerned
how can i choose between e5 and c5
well that's a good question i mean it's
like c5 is not that dumb here either c5
is an interesting move
but but here's my problem with c5 i'm
going to castle and ignore you
and then you can trade in the center
i'll give you that thank you malha's
gifting to create great owners raven but
the problem is that you haven't solved
the underlying issue of your bishop
i feel like e5 not only breaks in the
center but also opens up the diagonal
for black slide squared bishop
okay so
generally in these positions i would
prefer e5 so he castles this is still
the main line knight c3 rook c3 5 600
games
d5 95 95 queen e5 and yeah f4 is the
most popular move
queen c2 has about 11 games
yeah so bishop e6 of course bishop f5 is
also perfectly fine
and of course here rook d1 was a very
surprising move
i was expecting a3
why don't we want our bishop on b7 well
yeah we can put our bishop on b7 you can
play b6 but this is just a little bit
passive this is just a little bit
passive there are like 30 games in this
line queen c2 bishop
b7 but
you can get in a little bit of trouble
bishop d3 h6 bishop e4 and you're gonna
have a hard time defending the spawn
so it's just a little bit passive to
fianchetto in this position okay so rook
d1 he allows us to take the pawn
h3
yeah and here
i don't know if i
if i really played this accurately but
again rook fda
takes takes rook a3 wins the pawn back
right
um
so that's not very satisfactory
a lot of you were suggesting g6 but that
lets the rook get into d7 immediately
also don't like that so that's why i
played queen e6
but rook cd3 is a very nice move
okay so man of the raid thank you i'm
about to end but i appreciate it
i really appreciate it man
and good good good games
i am about to finish though
okay so rookie 8 rookie 7 is something
that you should remember
and people had questions at this point i
don't know what they
were rook d6 is another excellent move
basically forcing the queen onto an
awkward square and this move loses
because of rook d8 check
why not queen g6 asks alexander eve
after rookie six so it's the same exact
principle that i shared earlier
you have a pin going against white
screen but it's very easy to eradicate
it's just a one move thread i call it
one move itis where you think that
you know okay i'm stopping rook d7 but
white's just going to reinforce the
threat with a move like queen b3 your
queen might be out of the game here
i think maybe queen g6 is better but
you're not gonna stop rook d7 with that
move
okay
so a lot of people would make the
mistake of just automatically going rook
apa this is the definition of being
passive right
passive position means you have a lot of
pieces that are either in a defensive
role
or just not doing anything
i i don't like the situation white gets
in with the other rook this can get
pretty annoying yeah but b6 again rook
d6 and now you lose the c6 one so i
actually think this is the most accurate
here here
queen b3 is a great move aiming at the
b7 pawn
so i wouldn't think of it in terms of
good versus well you could think of it
in terms of good versus bad but
sometimes passive can be good right if
you're defending for example you might
have a fortress and that's another way
of saying passive defense right you just
bring all your pieces back you set up a
fortress and then you start moving back
and forth that's an example of
successful passive defense there's no
simple answer to the question mo yeah
most of the time you want to play
actively and you want to defend actively
well h6 is necessary
as soon as possible the problem is that
i don't get a chance to play it because
if i go h6 he goes rook d7
this is what i was worried about at
least but for some reason i thought i
have to take the rook in reality i don't
and i think the move b5
gives black a pretty good position here
so
maybe queen b5 was premature
so in any case we have this big trade
rook d rugby rook d5
a6 or c5 and here i'm forced to give up
upon because of the possibility of rook
c7 we certainly don't want to allow
doubling on the
c file
by the way if i'd gone with this rook
white has the very cute rook takes b7
tactic just something to keep in mind
so
not good
rook bc8 rook takes rook takes or takes
b7
and of course this should have ended in
a draw
this is just a dead draw but he went the
wrong way i mean already king d2 is just
weird i mean if you just
sorry if he just chills on f3 black is
never going to be able to move the rook
away from v1 this is a dead draw and
neither side can make progress here i
mean you've seen this a million times
so
this would have been a draw but i don't
know if he just totally collapses here
king b2 we give a check
here white should have brought the king
back to e1 probably still a draw
but this just loses all of the pawns
so a bit of an anti-climactic end to the
game kind of weird but
uh definitely
i'm glad we got a chance to play this
opening it's a very solid system
and i'm going to bore you guys to death
for the next 500 points of the speed run
just playing super
solid
you know kind of conservative stuff
and and that's what we're going to work
on the speed run is building those
very
basic fundamentals
because trust me if you want to play
like tall or you want to play
aggressively
building up your ability to play boring
positions in my opinion is an absolute
prerequisite so
hopefully you'll find that instructive
we're just getting started but right now
i'm gonna go to bed guys
fun day a lot of bullet
got to 3 300 at the end of the day and
we did a speedrun game so
nice productive stream
i'll definitely stream tomorrow probably
earlier in the day maybe after the world
championship
and in the meantime i am going to raid
my friend zura java hodze at les chess
live he's an international master living
in texas good friend of mine
uh so enjoy his stream giving your love
thank you guys for hanging out thank you
cellway for the sub
have a great night see you guys later
bye
[Music]
you